okay okay it's your voice like a pebble
here okay you know just the classic just
the classic um it's been a while since I
played this I gotta admit like I've been
getting to that no man sky [ __ ] you
know me and [ __ ] meet my wife huh
holy [ __ ] that is one fat [ __ ] oh fun
you see why it's doing that I had to do
that because that was one fat [ __ ] okay
okay so how do I let's let's get a
vehicle delivery yeah you know what I'm
saying which a dog [ __ ] ass didn't I
play right here um okay what mission we
gonna do okay okay Pierce Pierce old
sword sent over a couple pallets of
saints words maybe we should do a little
advertising around town you know pimp
the saints are still bored do we have a
PR department to them people go crazy
over actual celebrities promoting
themselves so you're saying it has to be
me oh I'll do the selling you just get
my bag can I have the perfect places to
hit that's good God cut okay i don't
know why they get my car but that's fine
jay says I'm kind of fast huh I can
either way sir Trey's ass anyway I oh
it's been there in there I guess you eat
a lot of bacon without more than usual
um yeah I guess I just Benny up being me
and I'll do my huh that's all I do a
psycho babble um yeah yeah yeah chef
all the way sir it's my exit sorry sorry
oh [ __ ] dammit turning a so dope on ya I
gotta set
okay okay
oh [ __ ] because that you can't use that
break when you're in the air to do this
fast check out the [ __ ] white [ __ ]
okay okay sorry i was talking when the
guys calling on even know what the [ __ ]
don't know but I'm sure I'll be
explained I don't know
okay okay Pierce what part of town he
was selling it first let's cut right to
the heart of this [ __ ] hit the Morning
Star territory how do you know which
hoods are there's the documents we got
with those keys gave up a whole lot all
right let's go make some morningstar mad
what sort of stuff are we selling some
piece of merchandise you know like
shirts and lunch boxes you think that'll
do the trick well there's always my demo
tape now we're talking dad cut okay keep
moving watch me do this she should be
dancing the dealership yeah wow what the
flying [ __ ]
hey okay okay thats Sarah less cheers
man it's all closing to do Oh nicely and
bat your eyelashes I don't think that'll
work immortal you know chef
the [ __ ] like a hair right down here we
go
jay says [ __ ] is getting real here look
the guys trying to like share data but
he's like a [ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ] shit's
gettin [ __ ] real here yeah things like
stun matter light house like at the [ __ ]
okay and I'll stop right there well I
thing keeps switching to the anger name
this thing is totally you
[ __ ] chat
how do you [ __ ] reload yeah please
work Pierce you're really good at
selling stuff [ __ ] right I am I'm
thinking you should start selling
insurance or maybe vacuums naku naku
well that's right that's what EJ said he
sounded sell vacuums because they lack
that is [ __ ] up that's all i gotta say
that is [ __ ] up I can't ok well I
can't doubt that take a villain or not I
can't tell so I got the lemonade has
picked this up another time gotta work
on my technique sounds good to me Willa
noise tend to get more later ok
okay look at chance and play
it's out for Harambee